je me souviens plus trop comment tout ça
a commencé
j'ai parfois l'impression que ça a
toujours été ma vie
pour rire
tuerie
je m'appelle alice et ceci mon histoire
la fin de mon histoire
il y a dix ans à raccoon city il y à une
épidémie
elle s'est répandue dans le monde entier
en quelques jours
d'une manière ou d'une autre notre monde
touche à sa fin la question est alors
nous mourir avec lui
elle a développé un antivirus il
pourrait détruire le virus t je n'ai
aucune raison de croire ce que tu dis
c'est vrai mais je peux t'offrir ce que
tu soit le plus c'est quoi ta bonjour
veut arrêter tout ça
je dois retourner mois
c'était compagne
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va les tuer
jusqu'au dernier
sort l'artillerie genre connaît un rayon
ça fait longtemps qu'on joue tous les
deux mais la partie est finie
[Musique]
c'est tout ce que tu as parce que c'est
ça je vais te tuer
[Musique]
ah ah